mahmoud abbas poursuit sa tournée au
maghreb en vue d'inscrire la cause
palestinienne au coeur des discussions
du prochain sommet de la ligue arabe en
mars prochain à alger après trois jours
passés en algérie où le chef de
l'exécutif a annoncé une aide de 100
millions de dollars à son homologue le
chef de l'autorité palestinienne est
attendu aujourd'hui à tunis bassam chez
lui
après une rencontre avec le président
algérien abdel madjid teboul le
président de l'autorité palestinienne
entame aujourd'hui sa visite est
tunisienne en vue du prochain sommet de
la ligue arabe c'est ce qui ressort d'un
bref communiqué de la présidence
tunisienne qui n'a pas précisé la durée
de ce voyage officiel de son côté
l'ambassade de palestine en tunisie a
indiqué que mahmoud abbas sera
accompagné par son ministre des affaires
étrangères et des immigrés son
conseiller aux affaires religieuses et
aux relations islamique son conseiller
diplomatique ainsi que son ambassadeur
en algérie fayez abu aita abbas avait
débuté dimanche une visite en algérie et
rencontré lundi le président de majid
teboul avec lequel il s'est entretenu
des pratiques de l'occupation
israélienne et des derniers
développements concernant la scène
politique en palestine cette visite
intervient pour parachever la
coordination entre l'état de palestine
et l'algérie afin d'inscrire la cause
palestinienne comme le point central de
l'ordre du jour de la réunion de ligue
arabe
le président palestinien a discuté avec
les dirigeants algériens des
développements de la cause palestinienne
des violations israéliennes contre la
mosquée al-aqsa et aussi de la
colonisation israélienne
l'algérie connu pour ses positions
historiques en faveur de la cause
palestinienne ne faiblit pas dans la
solidarité qu'elle exprime en verre à
pays qualifié de frère écoutez nous
réitérons le soutien de l'algérie au
combat du peuple palestinien jusqu'au
recouvrement de ses droits bafoués la
question palestinienne reste pour
l'algérie et son peuple non seulement
une cause sacrée mais également centrale
depuis hier la capitale tunisienne s'est
ornée de drapeaux palestiniens pour
cette visite officielle une visite
durant laquelle le chef palestinien
devrait inaugurer le nouveau bâtiment de
l'ambassade palestinienne à tunis de son
côté le palais de carthage a indiqué
qu'aucune conférence de presse ne sera
donnée à l'issue de cette rencontre